hello i am ran through g 4 2010 utah
state nice to geographically challenged
i'm here today at brighton ski resort in
the Wasatch forest of Utah I really like
the skiing you talk because of all the
really good snow on the ground this is
caused by the Great Salt Lake the grand
salt lake is one of the largest lakes in
the u.s. its own large effects muster
the weather in the salt lake area
besides its excellent ski resorts guitar
has many other favorite sites for
example attempt of square temple square
is a 15th most visited place in the US
which means about a million people that
place every year these halls also known
for five national parks arches rice
happily Canyonlands and science natural
utah is so plus natural scenery that
nearly seventy percent of all Everett's
land is covered with national parks
national monument see that divorce etc
besides Utah's many natural for
parks and other things youth also has
many natural walkways and small rivers
perfect for fishing hiking and other
outdoor activities force magnificent
scenery it's stunning mountains and
bountiful wildlife you should definitely
make you tires one of the places you
want to go one of the places I've always
wanted to visit is Europe I really want
to visit Europe because of all the
diverse culture the interesting history
the beautiful landscape among other
things some places I especially want to
visit for the big ben tower in London um
florence italy and the rhine river basin
in germany to study for the National
Journal Philby I primarily use two
things the internet temples on the
internet I searched up a lot of
information on sites mainly in kapiti on
books I used books I've had a lot of
geographic information but I also use
books i had like questions in them such
as a thousand and one questions by
cermak rosenberg and geography de
mystified by rama besides geography i do
other things most of this involves p.m.
my favorite composer is so long I really
like his music because it's really
dynamic and expressive my second most
favorite composer is rock mana that is
basically because i like his piece the
most out of all the pieces on
well the name of the piece anyway is
Rachmaninoff a to tape flow opus 33
number seven or eight depending on the
publisher it's all really confusing
because of something that happened then
it's too long to tell oh and did you
know one kind of hippopotamus milk as
about 1,500 calories you can burn all
these calories off by banging your head
against the wall for ten and a half
hours I like sports but my most favorite
is soccer when I play soccer I'm usually
on the defense because that's my best
position and I'm relatively good at it
and my teammates call me the wall I
really like soccer because it involves
complex footwork and on the spot
thinking which requires just mental
capability like the average American kid
I play video games I mean who doesn't
really uh well I usually play my PSP but
otherwise not so much I especially like
Star Wars even though it's really
outdated and really bad graphics but
over the past few years being green has
been a very hot topic I think being
green means being environmentally
friendly such as using renewable
resources instead of non-renewable
resources protecting those non-renewable
resources for future generations and
planting more trees and not littering
and things like that National Geographic
has helped me expand my knowledge of the
world around me its magazine is my most
favorite it's also probably because that
is my only magazine well anyway I would
really like to thank National Geographic
for hosting and sponsoring its excellent
competition
you